Oh mustaches lady mustaches not often
talked about but often ripped off
violently why don't we talk about our
lady mustaches
well we surveyed the women of the
BuzzFeed office and found that 77% of
them are self-conscious about their
facial hair and 85% of them say that
their mustache is their worst enemy yep
and we are a part of that 85% waxing is
the most popular form of mustache murder
with about 40% of the office preferring
to wax it off as opposed to any other
method so we decided to turn a handlebar
homicide it's a lady bonding time and
we're gonna wax each other's mustaches
cuz it can't be that hard
so axing I know I spend a good amount of
money getting my mustache waxed amongst
other things that I wax but could I not
just do it myself its ladylike and today
we're waxing our mustaches I'm [ __ ]
brows I am a licensed aesthetician and I
specialize in brow shaping and waxing
for both men and women
Chelsea's gonna wax my mustache I don't
know why you're trusting me to do this
I've never waxed it before cuz I never
felt this beauty and putting my stache
in Mickey hands I don't like being out
of control so this is gonna be a new
experience and all I get okay we are
going to cleanse it remove all the oil
residue and cosmetics it's always good
just to get in and around the mouth a
few dozen you seem very thorough well so
go ahead and apply this on her right
side of her upper lip and smooth it down
just like frosting on a cake remove it
all on the way down this is where it
gets a little bit scary now apply the
waxing strip on top of the wax yeah I'll
hold you girl all right not too hard you
don't want to apply it too hard because
gonna grab a - you might
get off ok ready 1 2 now you're kind of
bleep I'm bleeding a lot
though this is one of the more sensitive
areas too because you have the most
nerve Indians at the Cupid's bow so many
fights to a mustache and it'll usually
hurts the worst very therapeutic so
we're gonna go ahead and use with oil
yes okay you ready to take on the world
- lift now we're gonna go ahead and
apply this unfilled both like scared and
also secure in your hands
I'm sure the hairlessness is fine but
that was a lot of to do do you feel good
I feel great I really like the friend
aspect of doing each other's moustaches
it made me feel more comfortable even
those you've never done it before this
is probably the thing I've been the most
embarrassed about the put on line is
like literally my mustache it's a very
real thing that I think every female
relates to very natural to have the
peach fuzz would you guys do this again
should we all like hang out now that
waxing lady I'm selling today I dunno I
thought I was fun
you're just bonding moment you thought
it's closer together like I trust you
yeah absolutely
that's didn't before huh yeah either
that as well what else could be watched
daddy what could be wax next Consensus
vaginas tune in later yeah I want my bad
boy I want to feel like what that feels
like